[Music]
breaking news at 11 o'clock the ACLU
filing a lawsuit against the Clark
County School District demanding that
the district Release Body cam video of
an altercation at Durango High School
last February the group filed that suit
earlier today a recorded video from
Witnesses show a school police officer
throwing a student down to the ground
and apparently putting his knee on the
student's neck a statement to eight news
now in the matter reads in part today
the ACLU submitted a lawsuit regarding
body cam footage from the Durango High
School incident this as a result of them
now releasing the footage in 30 days
ACLU is representing three of the kids
that were involved in that incident